All right, so let's see if we can think
through, or maybe guess what's going to
happen if TD lambda is run as an update
algorithm on some finite amount of data.
So we it, we give the system
some finite amount of data, and
then we run TD lambda with different
possible values of lambda.
And then we ask, alright,
the V that you've learned,
how far is that from what the V should
have been, if we had infinite data?
>> Hm-mm.
>> Alright so, I don't know,
let's see if we can figure out, or
maybe even guess,
what this might look like.
So, let's say if we use lambda
equals zero, so we do TD zero.
So after some finite amount data,
there's going to be
some amount of error.
Let's just you know,
I don't know, call it that.
>> Okay.
>> Now it turns out, empirically, if you
play with this, it's pretty typical for
TD one to give you worse error,
given finite data.
And now the important thing
is what happens in between.
So it could be like a straight line
if it was literally interpolating,
it could be kind of bowed up, but
it's actually typically bowed down.
So it's not so atypical to see a curve
kind of like this, that gets better.
The amount of error goes down as
lambda gets to some intermediate value
let's call it, I don't know .7.
It depends of course on this,
the particular problem.
And then kind of start to shoot up again
and it eventually hit the error for
TD one as lambda approaches one.
And so this is kind of the justification
for why we want to consider TD lambda.
That it's actually combining these
two different sources of information.
What happens at the end
of the episode and
what happens at each step, in a way
that actually takes advantage of both.
It gets you the benefits of both.
We're rapidly propagating information
and we're not getting a biased estimate,
because of the way that we're
using one step information.
So, you know,
it has some attractiveness to it.
>> Huh, did you pick 0.7 on purpose?
I remember reading a paper once
that suggested that basically
everyone uses lambda equals to 0.7.
>> I typically see 0.3 to 0.7 as values
where things tend to work out where
this bottom tends to fall,
somewhere between 0.3 and 0.7.
Personally I always use zero, because
it works better with the control.
I have had better performance and
better understanding of what
happens in the zero case.
But it is true that if you actually
run it with a finite amount of data,
it tends to bottom out
somewhere between 0.3 and 0.7.
>> Hmm, okay, that's worth note.
>> So that's actually all I wanted
to tell you about TD lambda.
I wanted to give you a sense of how the
equations are defined, and how they're
derived, and empirically, why this
is something we actually care about.
So, maybe we should sum up?
>> I'm big fan of sum.
Is this going to be an infinite sum?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you, I've been here all week.